we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
our next caller is from the 732 area
code caller what's your name and where
you're calling from hi this is Kyle I'm
from Philly
what's on your mind Kyle um so something
I've been thinking about a lot since the
election is this idea that the that the
left can you know take that Cour through
progressive politics but what worries me
is that there might still be like a
strong contingent of like people who are
neoliberal I mean and you know concerned
with not progressing progressive
politics you know what I mean like
especially with the sort of thinking of
you know the popular vote being 3
million higher in you know Hillary 16
election maybe yeah for Hillary maybe
that's just a sign that everybody who
supported her moved to the same few
cities and you know maybe gentrification
had a role playing with Trump's flux in
the first place yeah I mean there's a
couple different issues there one is
you're sort of talking about like
corporate Democrats right I mean it
sounds like what you're talking about
when you talk about this center of the
Democratic Party sort of like the
corporate Democrats that are that are
neoliberal is that am I right about that
yeah yeah yes you are I think that
there's something to that although if
you look at so there's two things
there's number one where is the country
going and number two where are our
elected officials going the country has
been moving to the left on just about
every issue for decades at this point if
you look at what percentage of Americans
think now that abortion should be legal
in most cases highest number we've had
since since roe v wade what percentage
of Americans believe that and this is
sort of said a law at this point but
that to people of the same gender should
be able to get married to each other
record high on that taxes should be used
to reduce income inequality that's up
that's a pretty left-wing position in
the mindset of America in many cases not
in other parts of the world you have
support for that that is higher than it
has been for a long time
business regulations so I think what the
issue is sort of Pat is that while the
country keeps moving to the left the
elected officials that are able to raise
enough money to get themselves the
candidates that are able to raise enough
money to get themselves into office are
still sort of these corporate Democrats
at least on the Democratic Party and
that's what needs to be shaken up and
campaign finance reform is sort of a
good part of that absolutely it's also
interesting too because Democrats do
have an inherent advantage when it comes
to the electoral college because you
know so many people live in California
and New York that are voting Democratic
that you had just have these in your bag
it seems so for this past election it's
clear that it was lost in Pennsylvania
in Michigan and in Wisconsin that Rust
Belt area right so if we just pick the
better candidate say Bernie Sanders with
his left-wing economic populism there's
no chance that Trump would have been
able to beat him so you're you're now
fully jumped fully onboard with Bernie
would have beat oh yeah you're fully on
that I mean I understand you can never
really know for sure right because the
conversation during those few months
will be completely different the course
of history maybe they would have dug up
something scandalous and Bernie Sanders
passed we never really know but yeah
I've taken that position
okay so anyway I think that there's a
lot of interesting questions there I
don't know if we're really answering any
of them but I think that this deals with
some sort of broader issues among the
American Left yeah I think especially in
Philadelphia yesterday we had the we had
Larry crasner win the primary for a
district attorney who is committed to
you know working on lowering the prison
population especially with young black
men in the city which has been such an
issue for so long and I hope that it's
possible that the whole country can move
in a position where we're going to start
electing actual officials who are
committed to social racial and economic
justice yeah might be nice all right
thanks so much for the call really
really appreciate it on that note we
will go to a quick break facebook.com
slash david pakman show give us a like
on facebook we'll be back with more of
your calls after this